we are back and ready to begin a
seven inning game here in the second
game today between the rays and blue
jays
matt shoemaker three starts uh so far on
the season austin meadows he was in left
field in game one he'll d-h
here in the second game and a miss and
shoemaker strikes out his first batter
now brandon loud and back-to-back
strikeouts to start shoemaker's
afternoon
well we always talk about starting
pitching sets the tone for your ball
club
and boy what a good start another
splitter here's joey wendell
swinging to miss matt shoemaker strikes
out the side in the top of the first
here is jani chirinos coming off the
il cabin biggio in the lead-off spot
again
vizio hits a fly ball the other way to
left field he's hitting pretty well and
it's off the base of the fence on the
fly
digging for second and in there with a
leadoff double
here's randall grichik again up at the
two spot
brando hits this one hard back at the
wall
and in and out of the glove of kierbyer
and over the fence for a home run
he had it for a moment and he knew he
had it for a moment
but gretchen gets just enough of it to
send it over the fence
for a two-run homer minute first and
second nobody out
drury and that's a wave and a miss a
chase by drury
to pick up the first out in the second
inning well here's anthony alford
and the line drive to short quick throw
back to second
nice job by willie to go up and get it
and a beautiful job too by
brandon lau to scamper over to the bag
and get there before vlad guerrero jr
and the rays turn a line out 6-4 double
play into the last three
and here's hunter renfro the right
fielder batting eighth
and now renfro is swinging a foul tip
and he strikes out and just like that
two down
five strikeouts in the first eight
batters for
shoemaker randall kryczyk
and the fastball up strikes out kritchik
two up two down for chorinos in the
third
rudderwood first two down to oscar
popped up in foul territory his first
time up
got a pitch to hit and lines it into
left center for a base hit
shaw will put the brakes on as he comes
around second and another good swing by
oscar hernandez and that's going to be
it for chorinos
ryan thompson coming into the ball game
rowdy toles the
big left-handed bat with two men on two
bit out
and thompson's pitch a little number
left side
tough play but they have a little extra
time with tolez going down the line
and lau
and a base hit wow is aboard another hit
to extend his streak to
eight first walk given up by shoemaker
now the rays have a couple of men on
so now shoemaker will face g-man choi
make it bad right here for shoemaker and
he strikes choi
out battling back from a 2-0 count six
strikeouts through three and two-thirds
well it will be up to cesugo if the rays
are to cash in
the 2-2 sky to left field sending
alfred back that has carried it is going
to get out of here
an opposite field home run versus sugo
a three-run shot and the raves will take
a 3-2 lead
how about that matt shoemaker's
frustration boiled over and he was
tossed from the game by vic carapazza
evidently for saying something
from the dugout and then after that
charged out of the dugout onto the field
and had to be restrained
and charlie montoya he comes out and
talks to
cara paz and then he gets thrown out of
the game so here's vladimir guerrero jr
leading off the bottom of the fourth in
a game where everything has
seemingly changed and guerrero gets
into one no doubt about this one for
blatty and
thompson out curtis coming in now for
the raid and the first batter hill faces
anthony alford who lined into a double
play
and alfred lifts a high fly ball to left
field this ball is well hit
and it is gone anthony alford hits one
out of the blue jays go back
on top that is his second major league
home run
first and third one out meadows has
struck out and fouled out down the left
side
all right fly ball left center
alfred sets up to make the catch tag at
third kiramar is going to score to make
it a one-run game
now 5-4 yoshi homer did a three-run home
run in the
fourth inning facing anthony k to open
the sixth
two he lifts this one into left back
goes
alfred and it's over his head and it's a
double and the rays now have the
potential tying run in scoring position
aj cole comes on in a two on
one out situation here in the sixth
inning
and a ground ball to short to second one
to first
two two very very big outs for coal
and the blue jays austin meadows the
tying run takes the lead at first three
and one the count to diaz
and he sends one into right center field
that's going to drop for a base hit
bobbled and kick by hernandez
now meadows going to third and going to
try to score
and will how about that the rays tie it
at five
hernandez kicked it in right and the
rays have tied it
one on one out shaw one for three
shots it to the right side double play
ball out at second
out at first and the rays and jays are
going to go two extras
g-man choi who made the last out in the
seventh and he will be the runner in
second
padamus with a chance to grab the lead
and a fly ball back into deep right
that's what's gonna go
home run on the first pitch to adamus
and that takes care of that a two-run
home run
and the rays now lead seven
to five one out to get now vladimir
guerrero
probably hit ground ball third rosso up
with it
throw to first and the rays win it in
extra innings